if you came out and said i believe
america should enforce its immigration
laws
your right wing that's one of one of the
ways they've tried accusing me of being
a conservative is that they're like
tim poole has defended conservative
claims about immigration in the united
states
i'm like what is that what does that
mean bernie sanders was pro border
barrier in 2008 and and 2015 he said no
open borders
just because he went farther left
doesn't mean i moved but that's where
we're at
i mean you you can literally just say
something innocuous
and it's literally conservative because
the left has become so extreme and
revolutionary i suppose yeah and i also
think this moves in cycles i mean like
i'm a hip-hop kid and i remember
the moral majority in the 1980s
although tipper gore was part of this
but like chasing rappers and hard
rockers through the halls of congress
you know asking two live crew what a
coochie was like just
this ridiculous embarrassing crap i mean
just
you know and so that sort of thing like
had they gotten their way we wouldn't be
talking about parental warning labels on
rapper rock cds we'd be talking or i
mean imagine edm cruella and all that
you'd be talking about that not being
available
on the market like get it wet would be
available only as like a download from
some pirate site same with a dmx or
jay-z album
so that that was the right overextending
and i think we've definitely seen the
pendulum swing back into complete lunacy
this is one of the things that i noticed
a lot when i wrote taboo specifically
because some of it was intended to be
edgy like oh let's take on the alt-right
let's take on blm
but like the immigration chapter i
thought was just completely neutral
like at one point i think my description
was we should let in
sane reasonably able-bodied non-criminal
immigrants capable of getting jobs which
might involve some kind of basic iq or
aptitude test it's like well
wouldn't it and people started
describing this as sort of a far-right
proposal
like during an interview someone asked
me if i would let in disabled women with
aids
and i said i mean i kind of danced
around the question but it was just sort
of
i wouldn't prioritize that as an
immigration policy let's say
like there's an element of amoral common
sense that you kind of need to exist as
a healthy adult
and i think to some extent we need to
get back to
[Music]
let's say morally rational shared common
sense like the country's flawed but if
you openly fight against it we're not
going to say that you're the highest
form of patriot
this is one of the biggest problems we
have right now a far
right in the colloquial sense opinion on
immigration would be shut down oh
actually i think it's repatriated
repatriation is the third word so you
actually see these opinions on the
internet where people who are
time yeah they're like send them back
like but they live here it's like don't
care it's like okay that is weird
like they moved here they got
citizenship and you're like nope
all right then you've got a right-wing
opinion of we should
you know a further right we should lock
down the borders no more immigration
then you've got the right we should have
sound immigration policy
and then you have like the center right
where it's like well we're okay with
with refugees and asylees then you have
the center where it's like a similar
position
you start moving to the left and they're
like open up the borders increase the
numbers
if you if you entertain the centrist
position of
um like my position literally where they
claim it's conservative is
i think we should allow uh legal asylees
refugees uh
refugees to come into this country and
we should help them uh there should
obviously be some limit so we don't get
exploited like people who might come
from africa to brazil and then try and
come here
that's a lot of questions got questions
about that but cuba and mexico like
yeah by all means let's figure this one
out that's conservative
well i mean i i do think you need to get
into some of the technical definitions
like i
i don't necessarily think without
mocking your position that you'd be an
asylum seeker from mexico in any kind of
real political sense like
a lot of the countries this was one of
the things that struck me because i took
some time
off from standard academic writing while
i was working on the books and like
coming back into this debate
people are starting to use the term
asylum seeker for
immigrants migrant yeah but people
coming from countries like in
terms of a lot of the groups in chicago
mexico poland guatemala
guatemala actually would be one of the
central american countries that we're
supposed to feel the most
sort of heart rend for uh honduras
brazil costa rica costa rica is a
pleasant country it's amazing
it's a great place coda vita it's where
they film jurassic park great food i
mean it's just
but the idea that someone who's a tico
from costa rica
is a refugee is absurd
i mean right right right but so i mean
it's just
but that that's what i mean like i'm
talking about let's say there's somebody
who lives in a border city
in in mexico and they run afoul of some
gangs or something
and then they're like what do i do and
so they jump you know
they go to the border they go and say
they're coming for me what do i do
okay well that person we don't want to
die i mean it'd be if someone came in
the house screaming and panting and
threatened to like help call the police
i'd call the police
but that's that's that's not the
majority
so it's like what you said the left had
started calling all of them
asylees refugees aoc did it legal
asylees have broken no law and then
homan was like yeah they did they
violated this law and he reads it off
yeah so there are certain circumstances
where i can absolutely understand like
if a guy's being chased
and he runs through the river or
whatever to escape it's like all right
well you know i don't know what to say
to that guy like
get safe you know what i mean but what
we're seeing is people from africa
flying to brazil traveling up through
south america to the u.s border we're
seeing people from
these south american countries moving up
coming to america i'm like dude they're
economic migrants
yeah they get turned away well i mean i
think the the first
actually not anymore the first question
in response to even kind of the moral
component of that would be like if i
grew up in baltimore do you have
the right to seek asylum in japan that's
what i'm talking about no
yeah i mean it's there's an element of
so like looking at this point by point
as a political scientist like
if you're in mexico first of all if
you're in mexico and you're engaged in a
violent gunfight with the cartels you're
very unlikely to be a taxpayer
i mean like the old american mafia like
you're there are some
brutal abuses of women and so on and
coyote rolls but it's very
unlikely that the cartels and say a
group of policemen
are without any negotiations gonna
challenge each other to the kind of
fighting that requires one of the
policemen to flee here
if that happens sure i mean the border
cities
of mexico are extremely violent their
shirts all the time yeah well there i
mean there are shootouts in
american cities too actually we have i
mean like baltimore has a higher crime
rate than most of the cities on the
border i guess what i'm saying is most
of those shootouts involve the
equivalent of gang violence
right um but i mean so with at risk of
being like thought cold there are a
bunch of solutions here like first you
can move within mexico
mexico actually has funds that are
dedicated to helping people get away
from gang and cartel warfare
as we do by the way i mean we have
massive witness relocation programs and
so on
so i mean i think that would be my first
uh step if i were a mexican citizen and
patriot that
was having this problem i mean at the
another level like we could let people
into the country that could document
this um
and i mean i just improved version of a
polygraph test like that have to be
something
almost unpleasant they go through but
there'd have to be a period during which
you could stay in the country you could
have
for example a one-year protective visa
if you're not a traditional refugee
people forget this by the way refugees
and tps uh recipients are supposed to go
back
when the crisis is over so i think a lot
of this stuff on the left
becomes the endless extension of
compassion
where you see people that were displaced
by for example that awful earthquake in
haiti which is a legitimately terrible
thing
but 15 years later are still in the usa
and are not oppressed i mean many of the
not necessarily haiti but many of like
the black caribbean states are island
paradises i mean bermuda
bahamas barbados i mean they have
incomes on par the usa
so guys would be here running stores and
things of that nature like
i appreciate anyone's desire to hustle
and get a better life
but that's the same explanation people
give for selling weed like if you come
here from mexico or bahamas
in 99 of cases you're not an asylee
that's a far right opinion though
yeah i mean okay i'm far right on this
issue like almost every one of them i
mean i mean like media wise like i'm not
literally
saying like simply having a position
where you're like hey how does this make
sense
i i think it has a lot to do with
i guess tribal psychosis that their
people are so desperate to climb there
and claw their way to the top of the
social order on the left
that they're constantly one-upping their
opinions and accusing the other people
of being impure
so you get some person who like 10 years
ago was on the left and like i agree
with bernie sanders
well by that standard today you are a
far right you know
individual you're a you're a nationalist
you're evil or
all the really awful words they'll use
for you
how how are we supposed to have a
functioning political ecosystem if one
side
has no moral system or framework or
principles and it's just
i'm going to say the most extreme
extreme thing possible that moves me
further and further in one direction
one of the things that i think actually
is that there are almost no people that
actually believe this stuff
i i think you see the massive influence
of again the lower upper class
coastal urban very specific mostly white
liberal block on sites like twitter and
insta i mean
so there obviously that famous piece
came out i think wired that found out
that
what was it fifteen percent of americans
are on twitter at all
and yeah twenty twenty um what is i
think it's 22 percent of americans
are on twitter at all maybe yeah and
it's like a smaller percentage ten
percent are responsible for something
like eighty percent of the viral treats
so you've got
let's say 2.2 2.3 percent of the
population
that's driving this discourse and a lot
of it it's very disproportionately
first of all until pretty recent it was
also very disproportionately annoying
alt-right
uh pepes and groipers and so on they cut
out some of them but they haven't cut
out their opponents
so i mean extremely sjw heavy
a lot of a lot of tras a lot of trans
rights activists so on a lot of
positions that almost don't exist in
mainstream america
and i think it's important to keep that
distinction up like these people
influence the discourse that goes into
kind of
mid-level journalism like if you're on
twitter and you have more than 10 000
followers you're very likely to also
contribute articles from time to time to
say jezebel or something like that no
particular hate for them
so you have a lot of this scene in like
urban youth life
and it seems like it's very prevalent
but if you ask people like should
immigrants be able to read or something
like that like you'd see a massive
massive yes versus no in america let's
say you've got a hundred cities
with a hundred people in each city in
each city
is one socialist whenever there's
election
whenever there is an election the
socialist votes socialist and it
accounts for one percent of the vote and
everyone ignores it
then along comes the internet and now
you have a city-sized socialist
community online
because all the one socialist from each
of the hundred cities
now forms a massive community on twitter
where it seems like wow look at all of
these poli
these people it's like the size of new
york it's the size of a city
and then you're like oh it's just one
person in their bedroom in these
different places
the problem is it really does have an
impact look at
these these social these these uh big
brands will get harassed by this
community
and then they'll issue a public
statement on tv to tens of millions of
people
about how they now agree with this
fringe belief and they apologize for not
seeing it sooner
and the problem is it is true very few
people use twitter but twitter does have
influence hilariously it's stupid
and regular people don't speak up so
you'll be ruled by that two percent
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you